to present the awards for the best
documentary feature and short subject
here is a man twice nominated for Best
Supporting Actor and a young actress who
appears in this year's under fire there
also a father and daughter ladies and
gentlemen mr. Jack Palance and Miss
Holly palace
documentaries are a very special kind of
filmmaking move it easily the nominated
pictures speak for themselves for the
best achievement in documentary short
subjects the nominees are flamingos at
5:15
Cynthia Scott and Adam Szymanski
producers the nuclear shadow
what can the children tell us Vivian
Verdun row and Eric Thurman producers
sewing woman Arthur Dong producing
spaces the architecture of Paul Rudolph
Robert Eisenhart producer you are free
he brought me my lien Landis producers
and the winner is Domingo at 5:15
Cynthia Scott and Adam Szymanski
many final artists contributed to this
film but we would like to thank
particularly Paul Cohen and zooms all
Demers and the wonderful dancers from
the National Ballet School of Canada but
most importantly I would like to thank
the two great teachers of flamenco at
5:15 Susana and Antonio Roberto it is
their dignity their discipline and their
commitment to life which were the
inspiration for this film thank you this
film was produced by
we're funded by the Canadian public and
so on behalf of our 25 million investors
I'd like to thank the Academy very much
very proud
Leslie and Jennifer and Beth thanks good
night Polly
the nominated achievements in
documentary features are children of
darkness
Richard Kotick an era check mail
producers first contact god-honoring
Robin Anderson producers it makes me
feel like dancing Emil are doli no
producer the profession of arms war
series film 3 Michael Bryan's and Tina
vo Jen produces seen read James Kline
and Julia Reichert's the winner is he
makes me feel like dancing
it was harder to get up here than to
make the film what a feeling indeed it's
a very special moment and made more
special by the fact that there are so
many children here who were in the film
to share it with me I'd like to thank
the members of the Academy the superb
co-producer Judy Kinberg executive
producers at gosh Eric Scott Rudin sue
[ __ ] and I have to thank Lucy Johnson
who thought of the idea NBC
brilliant film editors Tom hanneke and
Charlotte Grossman cameraman Francis
Kenny Don Lenser and most of all the
extraordinary man Jack and woz a man who
really did take his passion and make it
happen in his belief that the arts could
transform people's lives and has
obviously generated such positive energy
and joy to thousands of people in New
York City through the National Dance
Institute thank you very much
I don't know I think they should have
let each of the kids talk